reactionary populism that's the name we
should be using for this sort of newish
right wing that some call trumpism our
friend Aaron rupar
uh I believe with a guest writer named
Noah berlotsky has a nice piece on his
sub stack called Elon musk's reactionary
populism I want to zoom out from Elon
Musk a little bit and just kind of give
you a foundation to think about this
movement because we it's very easy and
popular now to say Maga isn't
conservative jire bolsonaro is not a
conservative uh the these are we're not
recognizing traditional conservatism in
this new movement what is it reactionary
populist I believe is something that
encapsulates it reactionary populism is
a political ideology
characterized by
populist rhetoric and using populist
rhetoric for the people right that's
what we're talking about when we say
population
populist rhetoric to oppose Progressive
social and Progressive political change
so it often will involve rejecting
established political institutions a
defense of Traditional Values and ways
of life but under the rhetoric because
remember populism is a rhetoric rather
than a set of policy ideas using the
rhetoric of populism for your opposition
we're against this trans stuff
because of what's best for the average
person and the people the average girl
playing sports the trans stuff is bad
for the so they use populist rhetoric to
oppose
relatively standard at this point quite
frankly Progressive political and social
change they focus on Nostalgia for a
past that may not even have existed
that's an important thing to understand
they refuse to acknowledge and address
the challenges that we have today
through this nostalgic focus on a past
past that may or may not have been real
they will resist the progressive social
and political change which can actually
hinder progress and hinder social
mobility in many cases they reject
established political institutions which
will often lead them to ignore the rule
of law that's sounding pretty familiar
when we think about Donald Trump and
mega trumpism they will defend
Traditional Values and ways of life but
not with the traditional conservative
rhetoric they will defend it with
populist sounding rhetoric which can
trick people and this is how some left
Wingers fall prey and victim to
right-wing populist rhetoric they will
often promote nativist and protectionist
policies like around immigration uh
justifying it by saying this is what's
good for the people and of course in so
doing they'll harm global trade they'll
destroy alliances with other countries
as we saw under Trump they will resist
globalization generally they will resist
immigration they will resist social
diversity all using the pseudo populist
rhetoric of what's best for the people
and as we saw during the covid pandemic
the reactionary populists will often
reject evidence and expertise and that
can undermine public policy it can
undermine decision making it can
undermine the country coming together to
actually deal with issues perfectly
describes what happened thanks to the
Maga right under during the covet
pandemic under Donald Trump the reality
of course is that while the reactionary
populists will use rhetoric that sounds
like maybe it's sort of left-wing it's
not in the sense that this reactionary
populist movement is associated with the
far right far right political movements
extremists
Etc and it will all be under the guise
of we are under threat they will use
fear we are under threat it's a
political ideology rooted in reactionary
right-wing conservatism in a nationalist
worldview but it has been sort of passed
through a populist rhetoric filter so
examples include Trump of course the
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
um French politician Marine Le Pen
Brazilian president former president Jr
bolsonaro these are leaders whose
supporters will often espouse populist
sounding rhetoric but they oppose
Progressive political change they oppose
Progressive social change they appeal to
a Nostalgia that may not exist and they
at the end of the day when you get to
policy which you don't always get to
with the reactionary populists they
promote nativist policy protectionist
policy and reactionary policy I think
that's as good a name as any reactionary
populism let me know your thoughts check
out Aaron and Noah's piece and we'll
follow up about this again before you go
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more please make sure to subscribe
to my YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description